one way to
um
to
sense this
is
through
you could say
vibration or
um yeah i think that's probably the best
way to describe it um quantum
mechanically so like the vibration of
two entities or humans let's say
um
in conversation with each other and i'm
just gonna blow this up out of
proportion just to make it a point to
make it easy to understand
but
where one human let's say is more
meditative and has a deeper sense of
peace and equanimity and happiness joy
um
and then the other human has a
um
high levels of stress and high levels of
agitation
and high levels of
anxiety and maybe even depression
and
um this one typically thinks that
they're a victim of the universe and
this one typically thinks that they're
the creator
of their reality and so
then
um
then the way yeah the way that these two
interface you could say vibrationally is
that the creator the more meditative the
easeful one you could say if you want to
follow some of the eastern as well
tradition that the chakras or the energy
centers inside of the body are less
blocked and so in the torus
right of the flow of energy in the body
in the central nervous system up the
actual spinal channel and out the top of
the head
that that
is less blocked but in the one that has
a greater dis ease
those the channel and the energy centers
are more blocked and so the words that
come out of the mouth of the one that is
more blocked are typically the words
so you can sense it bodily based on
vibration but you can also sense it in
the words that they speak
right the logos these words are very
telling of like the state of the
frequency or the vibration that the
entity is at so for example for them
they might speak
in ways that are trying to extract
something to make them feel good
um to make them feel worthy or get some
validation or something like that
they want to get peace from outside of
themselves
and then just to briefly contrast the
one that's more meditative is typically
speaking or using words in ways that are
trying to serve
life
from an emptier place from a place
that's already whole or already
fulfilled and so you can tell by the way
people speak vibrationally you could say
quantum mechanically
so is the the knower
the observer perhaps i don't know what
the right term is but the one who is
more
at peace with themselves acting like an
energy sink
yes
drawing out of the negative energy of
the of the
of the observed yep it is interesting to
me from a physical
perspective because i stumbled onto this
whole um
homology between a black hole and a cell
so this
um beckenstein back in the mid 70s had
discovered he was trying to determine
the
total energy of a black hole and
contrary to what he had expected that it
was going to be
related to the volume of the black hole
it was actually related to the surface
area
and so i started and
because of the the similarities between
a black hole and a cell in the in
context of gravity
um
i always forget this term something so
basically the the there's a horizon
element in the black hole and i i am of
the opinion that the cell does the same
thing in its ideal state its information
its being is on the surface and that if
you are in a negative if you are that
observed
person who is
in kind of a negative state of
consciousness
that the the information is is uh hidden
but that you can extract it
right through the way in the way that
you described something like that
that makes sense yeah
and as as you were referencing earlier
it's um important where
if the one that has the energy blockages
is interfacing with the one that's more
free and does not have the energy
blockages
typically what's happening is that the
one that is more free is typically
reflecting
something
to the one that is more blocked so the
one that is more blocked is typically
asking the one that's more free
for this reflection
and the one that's more free provides
some sort of reflection
that then for the one that's more
blocked they'll like go through an
internal process of
of going to wherever that block is
energetically and liberating themselves
from that block so say
that um i'm speaking in a way that's
manipulative because i'm trying to get
people to see me for my self-image and
to think that i'm really cool
um so then what usually the one that
will reflect will do it will reflect
something
to the one that's trying to get
validation by
through self-image
and it'll get them to recognize that
pattern of behavior
and then simply by seeing that pattern
of behavior that they were expressing
they can then free themselves of that
pattern of behavior and just feel
automatically whole or more free rather
than needing to extract validation or
trying to get people to see their their
self-image to feel whole so it's simple
things like that with like reflecting
behavioral patterns
um
or um another one so in in just briefly
also it's because the work has to be
done by the entity themselves the work
is never done outside of the entity the
work is always chosen by the entity
themselves to go into the space where
they don't want to go you know shadow
unconscious subconscious etc
and by going into those regions
that's exactly where
the transformation happens the
caterpillar becomes the butterfly if you
will the metamorphosis happens
transmutation transformation alchemy all
those good things happen
simply by turning to the areas inside of
oneself where we don't want to go
and that if we just go
that then we can actually feel free and
freer in our expression and actually
more in service to life and less trying
to get something out of it
yeah yeah well actually even considered
in that
you know lateralization in the left
right brain
when you and i look into one another one
another's eyes there is not you
eliminate that
left right dichotomy right
so
you know in the
capacity to do that in an authentic way
may not be you know like a switch but i
think it
it has something to do with that
authenticity of that interrelationship
is my sense oh cool
what you just described i mean is this
all coming from eastern vendetta uh the
dantic um theory or
or uh belief
or is this just your own way of
understanding
the inter relationship of the two of the
the two inter you know
uh parties involved
where is it coming from what you just
expressed to me um
i would say um mostly through direct
experience and then
[Music]
the just the distillation of
um what is most cutting edge about that
possible
so
um yeah just the synthesis of all of the
peak of scientific literature as well as
spiritual literature as well as direct
experience with this process
we have an organization called the no
limit society
we're basically training free agents for
the ignition of global awakening and so
in this process we have hundreds of
people coming from around the world that
are interested in how to sort of empty
themselves of their own self-interest
and their own self-image and their own
ego and shadow and subconscious and
whatnot
and be more like empty vessels
for
the life waking up to itself and how to
like architect out these
nations
around the planet
that are decentralized
that have the basic needs be met that
swim in abundance energetic abundance
awake abundance i mentioned to you
earlier this shambhala and so you could
say it's um
it's both like
a
um
it's like buddhists and vikings at the
same time right so you have like the
elon musk entrepreneurial excitement
creation but at the same time you have
the buddhist realized awakened ones
and so it's a it's like the simultaneity
of that um so yeah mostly through direct
experience and also through
um through my team here through
the different scientific and spiritual
literature and distilling that and just
parsing for signal above everything else
like just parsing for truth for signal
above everything else because there's
just so much
um to try and swim through and like and
learn um but if you find what's most
um salient most relevant um the needles
in the haystack if you will um an
accumulation of thousands of needles in
a lifetime swimming across different
haystacks
oh my gosh those needles just compound
on each other and then we can describe
the physics of metaphysical phenomena so
like in this case these two entities one
feeling more free one feeling more
blocked we can actually express at a
scientific at a physical level what's
happening metaphysically and it's it's
so so interesting